he doesn't describe your character as
kind of a love story between you two you
think there's a love story element to it
and the fans see it as well
isn't that true it's hard it's hard to
hide yeah do you know what it's like
it's that thing in a love story where
you don't always like the person you're
in love with but you still love them
yeah and this is the thing Charles and
Erik always hated the way that they
approach things he's like he's always
wanting to kill the humans he's always
going on about the same old [ __ ] and
yeah I just I love the guy I can't kill
him I don't want him mind-control him I
love him that's right that's really nice
it is fans have come up with different
nicknames I don't know what you
preferred you liked Faso boy
do you like Mick bender bender with been
a lot also Mick fasi but he's good I
think Mick benders the winner I've been
a genetic right Jarrett you know the
fans have felt the same way about your
characters and a lot of them have edited
scenes of the two of you together to
Coldplay's Fix you over to Lou let's
take a look at that right now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and we've done something incredible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm on my side
that was beautiful you guys are really
moved by that yeah you're gonna be okay
you're gonna be okay - nose got muddied
in a mess
[Applause]